hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the Magnus Invitational we
are continuing with the match Allah
resolution vs. onigiri after that
craziness between magnets and nipple and
that was really some supreme flagging
action that happened in India Armageddon
game and if you know judging from the
comments I understand you enjoyed that
one
but here the these guys are playing for
something very valuable well not Holly
Rizal Reza has only three points and he
can no longer reach the playoffs but
Geary could still maybe reach the
playoffs if he beats on Reza and then
beats Fabiana Khurana now in the final
round of the preliminaries and Fabio
needs to lose both of his matches for
for gierek to catch up the fabric so
both of them would be on 10 points but
still I don't know if that will will be
enough for forgiver to qualify but still
he needs the try so this is Game one and
he has the black pieces against Valusia
so ali reza opens with d4 and knight to
f6 by giri we have c4 e6 Knight f3 and
d5 queen's gambit is on the board with
decline is on the board Knight to c3 and
Bishop to b4 again with the order goes
in defense
we have III and the castles and hereby
of the d2 will be six preparing to India
to the light square Bishop seek after
Sun d5 a trade in the center and rook
the c1 so all standard error goes in
stuff Bishop to b7 and now most calm
move here is just Bishop to d3 continued
development Castle and play to play the
game on but here nice the b5 by Allah
Reza
a very rare move that was played only in
one game so far which basically just a
trade off the dark square bishop so ok
gierek trades with Bishop captures and
now in that game we mentioned Queen
captures was played but he rallied as it
goes for Knight captures and it is as of
move 10 that we have a completely new
game so Geary pushes the knight back and
now tonight just goes back to c3 so this
night to b5 plan was that with the idea
of trading over the dark square bishop
s' leaving white with only the light
square bishop and hopefully it will be
not as useful as whites light square
bishop but as you often have it in the
Indian defense for indigo scene you will
often trade their slides for this report
by by just developing it to a six so
rook to e8 and Bishop to e2 now Ali
raised a continuous development and now
Bishop to e6
so Geary was waiting for Bishop d6 y for
a laser to waste a move and only then
play it so we have castles and now
Bishop captures any tube we have Knight
captures any to end now Queen to b6
continuing development keeping an eye on
that c6 pawn and here Queen to a4 piling
up on that c6 pawn making it a bit
difficult for black to develop and
here's c5 really does seem like like a
principled idea you don't want to keep
this backwards pawn but Geary get rid of
ends it in a different way he doesn't he
doesn't advance it but rather he plays
a5 and now he's gonna defend it with
rook a 7 to c7 and then bring this rook
over to c8 okay ali reza will also
double up on the C file Roxy 3 we have
looked the a7 and now rook F the c1
piling up on that c6 pawn with rook the
c7 defending and now Knight the g3
we look at the c8 by giri now even maybe
preparing to go with c5 but it's a bit
weird because okay your c c6 pawn is
defended but if this trade ever captures
here then the a45 point is weak but but
okay with Knight to f3 and now Knight B
to d7 now the knight from coming to the
game as the c6 pawn is defended three
times and 931 shifting the night over to
d3 to keep an eye on e5 and c5
so g6 not allowing Knight to a5 and the
night study three now with h5 by every
preparing age 4 and f3 now with h4
knight back to f1 and just King g7
improving the position of the King with
a 3 and now comes h3 trying to create
some King side weaknesses and here ali
reza just goes g4 so not allowing this
Knight any jumps all of these squares
are nicely protected and finally Giri
goes for c5 so Knight to f4 first just
going after the h3 pawn and here Giri
decided to defend the pawn with the
rogon
he played rook to h8 and this is all
well now the point is defended but now
you will have problems with your c5 pawn
here at night the g3 by allah azza and
here Giri goes Knight the f8 just trying
to ship this night over to e6 but this
this requires him to abandon the defense
of the a 5 point but it's what Giri goes
for with Knight to f8 and D captures on
c5 now making sure that now the a5 phone
will be left defenseless will be
captures and Queen captures on a5 so
here Alireza just grabs upon which
really makes it the whole idea of a5 and
shifting the rooks like this kind of
weird and not pushing c5 right away but
ok yeah we have Knight a to d7 bringing
the knight back and now g5 just pushing
that night all the way back Knight to
the h7 and now this night will have some
problems regarding how to re-enter the
game Knight captures an h3 also defends
the g5 pawn and grabbing yet another
pawn so here our si is up 2 points we
have looked the b7 now going after the
b2 pawn and should you defend it Gary
will just pile up on it with with rook
to b8 and it will be very hard to defend
it so ali reza just decides to give back
one pawn
so before we have capture status and
rook captures on v for now so still he's
up upon and f4 now defending this point
and now the h3 knight can once again
re-enter the game with Knight h2 f8 it's
time for Gary to reactivate his knight
and nights to F do now we have night the
e6 and rook the c6 now Knight the e6 is
a mistake by Gary as it allows our ace
at this rook to c6 move which now forces
Gary to give up the d5 point as well as
the Queen has no squares from from where
you can defend it so we have Queen to e7
and now Queen captures on d5 and again
Olga Raisa up 2 points we have night ETF
8 and now comes Queen to d3 just keeping
an eye on the e3 pawn and alga reza will
slowly start to enjoy his two extra
points we looked at age 4
but now night after e4 and
we have a king to h7 we've looked the c7
now going after this night here you will
be able to attack at plenty of times you
might imagine some ideas like characters
here you give up the rook Knight
captures Queen captures and after Queen
captures Knight f6 check pics of the
Queen
so even ideas like that are possible so
first Queen to east expiry and now comes
in night 2 f2 here if you if you go for
this like we mentioned with rook
captures here and then tonight captures
and if you go Queen captures and now
it's it's a bit of a problem because
after Queen captures the knight f6 check
King g7 Knight captures it's okay it's
still two knights and the rook against
two rooks but white would still have to
work very hard for his meal so ali reza
doesn't force this which which I thought
he definitely would but instead he goes
Knight back to f2 and now rook the b3
sorry rook to b3 attacking our aces
Queen we have rook 7 to c3 offering more
trades and rook the b2 now we have
Knight g4 and now again keeping an eye
on that f6 Square and now otherwise
we'll try to improve the position of
asking get the King all the way here and
then get the other Knight to g4 to also
go after the f6 square so rook the b6
giri has to wait and see what Ali Rezai
will do as he is the one who is who will
be doing the pushing King G - we have
ripped the h5 and now King to g3 the
night covering h3 so you cannot
infiltrate with the Queen Queen to f5
and now Knight to g4 and now both
Knights are covering the f6 square and
you have you have problems here so Gary
you replay the King to g8 here but it
doesn't help if you go King to HH to get
out of checks because Queen d4 check
forces the King to go once again to a
light square or you play f6 and then
rook c8 and black is never holding this
so after Knight g4 we have came to g8
but now our eyes adjust goes after the
f6 square night e to f6 check and this
just Forks the king and the rook we have
Knight captures Knight captures with
check and now sorry first holidays I
decided to trade Queens of course
character scatters in lonely now Knight
captures on f6 with the same fork
now route captures on f6 you have to
give up one of the rooks so give me the
sides it's better to give this one up
and maybe well mess up White's pawn
structure a little bit so King to h7 and
now rook the c8 going after the knight
96 and now rook to d1 with the idea of
just a nice rook lift here we have King
to g6 and now rook the d5 and here we
have King captures and f6 Robin d5 is
with the idea that if King captures you
have this e for push which Giri goes for
we have captures and now efore so you
cannot capture as the Rockwood Hank
so nine g7 defends the rook and the f5
phone but now d5 with check King g6 and
now rook the g8 and here of course ali
reza is just preparing it to bring the
other row cover to the back rank and
that's pretty much it a black will have
no more moses so here give replay to
King gauge 7 and after rook D to d8
it was in this position that uh nigiri
resigned the game and the game one of
their match goes to ali reza so here you
resign because you have no moves this
rook is never entering the game and well
there's just after this check you're
gonna trade rooks and you're gonna be up
upon and of the exchange so whatever you
play here rookie Rookie
six let's say you're gonna go look the
h8 to check and after King g6 you can
either either capture or you can go here
check and after the knight blocks
exchange then and still you're up the
exchange end up a passed pawn which is
of course completely winning so here we
resigned and he will try his luck in
game 2 where he will have the white
pieces yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it it was a really it's hard
to say giri first first lost the pond
and another pawn there okay all there is
a gave one back as he decided he will
not be able to defend it or rather maybe
he will but he should sacrifice a lot of
activity and then giri gave up another
pawn so this is a nakamura give well a
short speech during the live coverage
that aside from for maybe Nakamura and
Carlsen Alireza is the most experienced
one in this field in online chess and of
course a lot more experience doing Eyrie
so these shorter time formats and
playing online definitely do favor him
but yeah we'll see how it goes is to
have three more games to go
and we're gonna cover that as well yeah
I would like to thank I think Venkat
Reddy K Lukas prattle Fredrick are her
now Joseph Bessette and Abdul Abdul
Moxon or AG for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it finishes so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day